still exciting
it's still good yeah and you know
vader's the reason it jammed peter's
just the other end of the hallway
thinking
yeah no just putting my foot in the door
just stopping it
maybe it's just a guy with asthma maybe
it's just a guy with asthma nope no it's
not
it's
how do we
like no none of us knew going into rogue
one that we're gonna get
the best darth vader scene
it's still my heart is pounding i'm
we're coming back to this too
oh god it's just like perfect vader it's
yeah flawless ah i have to applaud this
this is it's just i i will re-watch this
scene it's like this is up there with
the trench run with uh vader's duel with
luke in empire and in return of the jedi
like there's just some scenes that are
just re-watching and who would have
thought that that would have come up in
rogue one when we i know
that was definitely going into that
movie i was not expecting i tricked my
nephew into going to that movie my
nephew refuses to watch star wars
because he's a contrarian little bastard
and because i love it so much he just
won't get into it so i was like do you
want to go see a movie about aliens that
are fighting with guns and he's like yes
and then i got there and it was rogue
one and he was like this is star wars
isn't it but even he had to admit that
that was enjoyable so yeah i mean rogue
one doesn't have the opening crawl yeah
you almost can get away with it until
darth vader shows up on most parts yeah
the storm troopers gave him apparently
yeah
yeah that's true that's true he's like
almost got me uncle tom and and the
giant smile on my face for throughout
the entire movie
he saw my joy and he read that as a as a
deception the games the mind games you
play with your nephew i know well
they're more likely to know how to like
me i'm not smart enough to play mind
games
well hello there welcome back to new
rock stars
we just rewatched one of our favorite
sequences in all of star wars the ending
of rogue one because this is the era of
darth vader that we will return to in
just a handful of weeks as we wait for
kenobi
this is wikileaks our weekly reaction to
the latest in star wars i'm eric boss
i'm here with tommy bechdold we're back
on mondays tommy yeah way to start the
week with you monday fun day baby it's
like church two you know you get lifted
up at mass on sunday and then you come
back to wookie leaks on monday it's that
cup of coffee you need after all the sin
and you did all weekend you know i mean
church too is what we got when we fell
asleep during church that's right so we
had to go back and sit through the 11 30
service
or we didn't listen to everything the
priest said that's right or when they
tack on like a youth group thing at the
end of church they're like now we'd like
to encourage all the youths to gather in
the basement for donuts and a mixer it's
like no church is over
church is over
going to catholic school sometimes i'd
have to go three times a week
because
they they're going to rack up the
numbers
they really do i'm like i've already
been to church this week they're like
you got an alter server so i had all to
serve some other services during the
week exactly so i mean they're like you
got to punch your card a million times
before you get into heaven if you're a
cat yeah that's right exactly we have a
we we
uh we tee off from the from the uh
further back that's right from the
progress i don't know golf obi-wan
kenobi is coming may 25th on disney plus
and it's going to feature the return of
hayden christensen as darth vader which
is a fascinating choice it confirms we
will not just see the villain in his
classic mask and silhouette form but
also some additional form under the mask
that requires hayden to return for the
role so what forms is vader's human face
gonna take on this series
are we just gonna see clone wars
flashbacks or are we gonna see some kind
of force projected ghost or maybe some
creepy nightmare projections that haunt
obi-wan kenobi are we gonna see under
the mask like an iron man heads-up
display kind of thing or is he just
gonna be pulling a boba fett and soaking
the scars in a bubble back there the
whole time and that's how we see him oh
my god that's what we're gonna be
exploring on this episode it's just what
hayden christensen as darth vader is
going to look like on the show because
it's not just going to be the mask you
wouldn't need hayden otherwise for that
um so before we get into that the
special book of boba fett latest
obsession shirt is sold out over at epic
heroshop.com the previous latest
obsession shirts for no way home and
hawkeye are already sold out and keep a
lookout for uh uh an obi-wan kenobi
shirt late may it's i've seen some early
designs hello shirt it's pretty cool yes
this is the shirt you're looking for
hello
shirt
shirt me baby that's the catchphrase i'm
working on it's phillip's gonna hang on
to that one he'll like that that'll be a
baby we're gonna greenlight shirtley
baby as a shirt as well kenobi
what will darth vader's face look like
in obi-wan kenobi yes there is a reason
this series is bringing back hayden
christensen because if all they wanted
was darth vader they could have done
what they did with rogue one as we saw
in this opening clip they bring in a
physical team and that movie was spencer
wilding and daniel naparas and of course
that james earl jones doing the voice
over they could just do some version of
that now but no no no no they need
hayden's face his body his voice for
this one which tells us something about
what this show is cooking up for darth
vader the simple answer is that they
could just need hayden for flashbacks to
the clone wars era but that can't be the
only reason because the show producers
have promised a rematch between kenobi
and vader and i don't think they would
have hayden sit out that epic fight on
this series like to bring him back all
this time just to when it comes to the
one reason many fans are watching the
show to bench him and have the stunt
guys and j ej take over no i don't think
that's going to happen i think hayden is
brought back and he's going to be the
one locking swords with you and mcgregor
and that's not to say we won't see clone
war er era flashbacks that could be the
case we could see some flashbacks to the
revenge of the sith era you know that'd
be pretty fun to see some live-action
version of what we saw in clone wars um
but i also don't think this will be a
simple matter of hayden just being
scarred in a back to tank like he's
gonna have some active role yeah like we
did see vader in the back to tank in the
moose of our castle in rogue one that
could also be something we see but i
think the series is gonna have some
active element for hayden to do
physically the reason why you bring him
back i also don't think we're gonna see
hayden with his vader mask off as he
fights
obi-wan just because vader can't take
his mask off for long periods of time
you know without suffocating or dying he
needs a mask uh and i think it would
just feel a little lame to do an iron
man and just punch into his face under
the mask like just see the top of the
half of his face angrily yelling because
that could just be something hayden
christensen did like
in a green room like just have him sit
in a dark room and they shoot him he
doesn't need to be on set at all with uh
you and mcgregor to do that
um but we also have to bear in mind like
we're under all these little limitations
that are closing doors of possibilities
for how we're gonna see uh like it's not
like we can't see them in these ways but
like there needs to be one specific
one or two specific options for how
we're gonna see hayden at least on set
with you and mcgregor on the show and we
have to bear in mind that this series is
going to be set mostly on tatooine uh
during the era when obi-wan kenobi is
looking out for young luke skywalker 10
years old and the issue with that is
hardly anyone knew that obi-wan kenobi
was on that planet
uh uh bailor ghana leia
leia found out later r2 who knows
everything yoda i'm pretty sure knows
captain antilles found out when leia
found out and then of course uncle owen
and peru they knew um but darth vader
certainly did not know we didn't see
maul figure out where
obi-wan was until rebels so i don't
think we're gonna see vader and obi-wan
fight on tatooine i also don't know if
we're gonna see obi-wan leave tatooine
on this show he just may be there the
whole time we we don't really know yet
but i see two very cool possibilities
for what form hayden christians and
darth vader could take on the show the
first option would be an adaptation of
charles soules darth vader
dark lord of the sith comic series from
2017
we referenced that when we were talking
about mandalorian season two that's uh
there's an issue where we see darth
vader meditating and his self-projection
just looks gnarly it's like this
monstrous scarred form floating in a
kind of hellish space his but his like
lower half and his arms are white you
just kind of see the internal battle
projected that yeah in his mind and uh
perhaps that could be the demonic image
that continues to haunt obi-wan kenobi
um now in those comic panels you see uh
these like blue butterfly things we're
wondering if those are the same blue
butterflies that swarmed grosgu when he
was communicating with luke skywalker on
on titan we might learn more about what
those things really are but uh
that form if you look at the comics
doesn't even look it barely looks
humanoid right like the face doesn't
have any uh specific features that look
like anakin skywalker so the second
option i think we might actually see on
the series is a kind of force projection
because last week we talked about how
the series could show obi-wan kenobi
learning how to transform into a force
ghost from qui-gon jin as yoda promised
that we would see during this era in
revenge of the sith also in the last
jedi luke skywalker proved he could
project his consciousness remotely while
still alive and use that to fight kylo
ren so perhaps that will be what this
rematch duel looks like obi-wan learning
from force goes qui-gon how to remotely
project his consciousness to face vader
who could do the same thing
so we have his projection taking the
appearance of his unscarred you know
masculist self so that would make the
battle between these two a battle of
souls like a jedi in the sith trying to
drive each other insane with their
tortured solitude yeah they aren't
actually in a physically in the same
space but we still feel that those epic
stakes that we felt when they fought on
mustafar in revenge of the sith right
what do you think tommy i think that's
really interesting and i think that
gives once again the i think the
psychological high ground to obi-wan
because why would anakin project himself
as the version of himself before he
turned to the ways of the sith you know
like i mean before i mean i guess he was
technically
still anakin
before he went to mustafar but like that
version of himself represents the
version that was married to padme and
expecting children excitedly very human
very you know
good for lack of a better uh or a more
articulate way to say so obi-wan can
automatically use that in a in a battle
of wits of being like why is this the
version of yourself you're facing me
with you know why not why not your
current form which is the destiny that
you chose you know right and that might
be something that vader uses to get
under obi-wan's skin even more like that
would be harder for obi-wan to face
than this machine face you know that
doesn't have the eyes that he would look
into as a friend and as a brother all
those years i think it'd be harder for
obi-wan to fight a human face you know
um and i think that's that's the way we
get to it because if you think in a new
hope vader says a presence i haven't
felt since and just kind of trails off
but that presence could refer to
anything it referred to a battle on any
kind of plane of existence a a more
spiritual plane or a more physical plane
and
i don't know if i want to see just
another physical sword fight between
them because the battle on mustafar was
so great what what's going to be
different about that you know
just another fight but now it's vader
fighting ewan mcgregor like cool i'll
watch it don't get me wrong i will watch
it fine no
that would be cool but i hear what
you're saying it doesn't up the stakes
in any way that doesn't move their
personal journey together their
relationship along in any sort of
significant way if it's just a physical
battle you know like there has to be
there has to be some emotion and some
reasoning behind it why is this
happening is obi-wan still not giving up
on anakin you know is he is he is he
kind of like luke just relentlessly
going to try and pull anakin skywalker
out of darth vader and we just never saw
that in a new hope because we had such
limited time
to get all of this you know it's the
launching of the star wars universe so
yeah yeah i mean i guess what i am
pitching and some fans may balk at this
thinking it sounds stupid but
essentially we have vader in his uh in
his solitude and his castle we have
obi-wan and his solitude in on tatooine
and then they're just reaching out to
each other through the force and then
their mental projections of each other
and of themselves are fighting on some
kind of recreated hellish uh mystical
realm
are fans gonna look at that and be like
that's lame that's that's stupid they're
not actually fighting um or could they
see that as like no this is exactly the
version i want to see um because we know
both of these characters will survive
this conflict because they have
histories ahead of them or they have
futures ahead of them um but who's going
to win the mental battle who's going to
walk away more mentally scarred from
this battle and is there someone else
whose life is in a jeopardy right and i
would say not to go too far in
predicting but i would say that it looks
like anakin wins because in the end you
see ben kenobi in a new hope and he's
basically like a crazy i mean he's a
crazy wizard as they refer you know what
i mean like i mean he's still got all of
his like he seems pretty much like
resigned to just like
hanging out and tattooing right and like
keeping luke safe like
darth vader is out there
working on the death star and like you
know doing doing evil deeds so
i would say like
it looks as though if we take if this is
the way that it goes
anakin may end up with the upper hand
here um now to uh to be clear darth
vader i believe at this point in history
did not yet know about the death star
that was a galen erso krennic joint uh
and then vader once he found out about
it was a little perturbed by a super
weapon um the military industrial might
was always something that he never
suspected would be the answer to all of
those problems i guess i just mean he
was and he was ruling or he was he was
running [ __ ] with the empire pretty with
a pretty forceful hand he was uh yes
absolutely and i think you're right
tommy i think he will walk away the
victor from this um not just uh
they had that exchange when they dueled
on the death star like uh when we last
faced i was a student now i am the
master you know i think he's kind of
recognizing his own dominance as they as
they face each other again and he's like
taunting him he's like what are you
doing old man like
i thought we settled this right right
in those tapes yeah this is exciting
this is not yeah this is very unwanted
i'm just thinking like i i like that
hayden christensen's back i think he he
deserves some redemption for anyone who
might still have some misgivings about
his portrayal of anakin skywalker um but
like if it was just gonna be an obi-wan
kenobi show where he had a rematch with
vader just logically you do not need
hayden christensen to put on that
costume again and do all the stunt work
you could have anyone do it um so what
is hayden christian's gonna hayden
christians is gonna bring to the table
they need to have written something for
him to make that worth it they need to
have a moment between him and euan like
face to face
and to me the coolest way to do it is a
it's just like a new type of uh four
stool that we have not yet seen only
little bits and pieces of uh like in the
last jedi we saw it in uh the rise of
skywalker where kylo and rick right
right but not to the this level where it
would be
you know i mean also characters are
aware of it because kylo did not know he
was fighting with force projection and
uh for anyone who loves the sequels and
said that you know we actually do care
about rey and kylo yes i i do care about
them as much too but i think universally
everyone seems to like obi-wan kenobi
and uh and wants to see him fight vader
again yeah so that's all i'm saying
that's awesome i don't think that's an
unfair thing that's an unfair thing to
say i also think that the sequel trilogy
is unfairly maligned i'd never want to
erase it i love so much about uh those
movies yes they are flawed and they made
some choices that i'm not a big fan of
but i i really really like each of those
movies in different ways and i think so
everyone involved creatively should be
sentenced to
death so how do you feel about that no
i'm just
i i echo your sentiments eric i i feel
the same way as you do about them we've
talked about monetize for threats of
violence yeah
all right don't do it cut it out then
no leave it in leave it in we don't want
money from this video thank you to
bluetooth for sponsoring this episode
we're pretty confident in our theories
here on wikileaks and confidence can
take you pretty far in life and in the
bedroom and that's where blue chew comes
in blue chew is unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can plan ahead or be ready
for whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple you sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you will receive your
prescription within days and it's all
done online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door and discrete package so if you
could benefit from some extra confidence
when it's time to perform blue chew can
help and we've got a special deal for
our audience try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code of new rockstars at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluechu.com promo code
new rockstars to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we thank bluetooth for sponsoring the
show all right tommy um another
interesting thing that could be coming
up in the obi wan kenobi series is we
just spent you know seven weeks with
tomorrow morrison playing boba fett on
the book of boba fett but could timur
morrison return an obi-wan kenobi as a
clone trooper because we know characters
like commander cody could still be
around a lot of the clone troopers did
get killed or discontinued you know we
saw that in bad batch um
uh tarkin was like we do not need clone
troopers anymore we'll have recruits it
will be a homie um but characters like
rex did survive order 66 he's still out
there we know he makes it uh through
rebels he's still alive in this universe
uh and then of course the bad batch
they're still around somewhere and
tomorrow morrison as the clone
characters the face of all clones could
he show back up on this show well i
think they owe him two episodes of a tv
show based on screen time so i mean like
that's just uh
maybe just contractually they're like
hey we're gonna take two of yours out
but we're gonna throw you into a there's
just always gonna be a debt there's
always gonna be a debt in all of these
shows to to a certain character like you
and mcgregor's gonna have to get two
episodes of ahsoka somehow so it'll be
like it'll just always carry through
uh you know i don't personally
you know i don't
in my own
desires have a like a burning desire to
see him come back as a clone trooper i'd
like to maybe get some more exploration
of boba fett and possibly a different
way than the tv show went but
from what the response that i have seen
from fans of our channel
there is a deep desire for rex to make
an appearance on this show but it seems
like a lot of the people that
communicate with me on twitter and
instagram are dying for rex to appear in
this show in some capacity i am too i
mean rex i would say rex is would be
more fun to see return in ahsoka he had
that relationship with ahsoka and that's
you know i'm more interested to see that
pairing again really the clone trooper
who had the close relationship with
obi-wan was commander cody he's the one
who picked up his lightsaber handed to
him and then tried to murder him but so
we don't know what happened with cody we
but we assume uh or at least i don't
know what new chapters the story they
may tell with commander cody if they
ever do i would assume he would try to
murder obi-wan kudo if you ever saw him
again but i'm wondering the bad batch
right like how fun would it be to have
uh timur morrison's face mapped on five
different people as they come on save
obi-wan's life in some thing or save
someone else's life and even if even
just one episode even just a one episode
just one quick moment yeah that would be
wild that would be so fun to see crusher
like a big beefy clone with two more
morrison's face on there hunter you know
yes echo all of them yeah a lot of these
characters i think they're still around
i want to see them again
but uh yeah i think is it more
interesting to see more clone trooper
show up again or are we more interested
to see the live-action inquisitors get
started the inquisitors being the the
jedis who were uh who were enlisted
basically to hunt down the other jedi
that whole operation gets yeah
ooh
i mean i think i'm more excited to see
the inquisitors get up and running just
because that's such a diabolical group
so i think that's more that'll be more
fun to see in live action and
out like that so for me personally what
might be more fun probably probably the
bad bad showing up probably a little
less traumatic to see on screen but uh
yeah i think i i i hope tomorrow
morrison gets more screen time on the
star wars tv shows uh
and i'm sure i certainly think there's a
pathway for him to come in on this show
yeah i i think at this point now uh bad
batch is showing us the post
military life of the clone troopers
right yes they're still involved in
military operations and missions and
things like that but they're not uh
inscripted in any other kind of like war
at this point they're just kind of
picking their own battles
and that's what was so interesting to
see about rex and rebels is that life
was behind him so i think that's what i
would want to see with clone troopers
now i want to explore rex as a character
i think it'd be fascinating to see him
hang out with ahsoka um
especially since like
she hasn't really hung out with boba
fett right she has been in that world
but
never
around each other so it's just hilarious
that you know uh timor morrison's
playing both characters yeah she would
just see his face and be like rex wait
one of the other ones
which one are you
well we'll leave it there for this
episode of wikileaks we're going to be
on mondays from now until late uh may
right when obi-wan kenobi comes back um
and we're gonna be talking about
whatever topics you guys care the most
about with star wars that week so let us
know on twitter every week uh hit up me
and tommy if you have like a burning
star wars question now's the time to ask
it because we got a lot of time i mean
we'll have an obi-wan kenobi trailer at
some point soon hopefully but in the
meantime we're just gonna like react to
some of our favorite clips from star
wars we're gonna talk star wars because
we love it yeah we're talking star wars
every week with you guys so uh i love
that we get to do this and uh as long as
like
you know some people still watch these
we'll get to keep doing them so thank
you for watching for making it this far
thank you tommy for joining me as well
my absolute pleasure eric great way to
start my week i love moving it to
mondays because
things can only go downhill from here
you can follow tommy at tommy bechtold
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
and subscribe to wikileaks wherever you
get your podcasts thank you for watching
and goodbye
you